del ris hawaii
vincenzo salemme coppi
[Musica]
dai fammi una foto però fame da bene
poco spazio sopra la testa e poco spazio
sotto i piedi e prendi anche la stretta
tedesca e mezzo
queste foto piuttosto spiega mi cosa ci
facciamo noi due
un'altra volta sul palco del che dx e
dai profumi questa foto che lo devo
pubblicare
comunque siamo venuti per raccontare la
storia di farm ancora no questa volta
non raccontiamo ciò che già successo ma
quello che potrebbe succedere a carini a
favara e in tutte le nostre città se
solo noi provassimo essere un po meno
stupidi e aprissimo un po gli occhi
io dico che è impossibile cosa cambiare
favara no perché essere viene stupida
mamma povey portatevela prima che
ammazza che succede questa volta
possiamo lasciare con attivo da sole
senza litigare mamma quante 6 st cosa
che potrebbe succedere a favara disse
spazio nel 2030 la solita nichilista
potrebbero succedere tante cose che
adesso facciamo fatica persino a
immaginare se solo se solo provassimo a
ragionare un pochettino di più per
esempio prende le nostre città
cosmopolite le città in cui vivere bene
con un'ottima offerta abitativa con
opportunità di lavoro delle città
accoglienti per i giovani per gli
studenti per gli stranieri delle città
con una grande vita notturna papi ma
giusto nardi dover iniziare a bere
lasciala stare piuttosto spiegami ma
questo non dovrebbe essere un lavoro del
sindaco hai visto che avevo ragione a
dire che sei stupida viola 6 la solita
impertinente ma quanti di noi si
aspettano ancora che possa essere
il sindaco il presidente della regione o
il capo del governo a cambiare le sorti
della nostra città
vediamo in sicilia false o croce ci
credevamo carla la verità è che anche
quando cosa rara il sindaco o la sua
squadra di governo è mossa dalle
migliori intenzioni le emergenze del
quotidiano le buche la spazzatura
finiscono per far perdere la rotta e
allora allora ci rassegniamo mondo è
stato e mondo è l'educazione come quel
signore attacco ma come scopo quel
signore e capitava lambiasi gattopardo
tutto cambia per nulla cambiare la
solita nichilista e allora occorre
immaginare che arrivata il tempo per noi
cittadini iniziare nuovo a pensare a
progettare a costruire le città in cui
vorremmo vivere da un pezzo
allora aspettate che chiedo a loro e
vediamo cosa mi rispondono ma poi siete
contenti di carini
siete contenti della città in cui
abitate si onde di come quando sei al
primo appuntamento
il ragazzo più grande di tetti di
animali fighter peraltro mentre noi ci
lamentiamo per le nostre città per
quello che non c'è per quello che non
funziona
ventimila giovani ogni anno lasciano la
sicilia ea carini fan che di viola
sempre la solita quello che voleva dire
papi è che le nostre banche di favara di
carini di bagheria della sicilia e del
mezzogiorno esplodono di denaro
approvava si stima che ci siano circa
500 milioni di euro in depositi bancari
accarino orientativamente saranno poco
ma non è che se ne facciamo con tutti
questi soldi noi niente perché non
sappiamo organizzarci in altre parti del
mondo probabilmente li usano per
finanziare i grossi investimenti e
allora quale sarebbe
società per azioni buone cioè per una
volta cercate di essere comprensibili
anche per una bambina di nove anni
papi e carla ti vogliono dire che forse
bisogna iniziare a mettere insieme le
persone che hanno i terreni e fabbricati
e anche gli immobili che hanno un grande
potenziale trasformativo le persone che
hanno dei risparmi in denaro le persone
che hanno delle competenze per gestire
queste risorse e rendere le nostre città
migliori
pensate che se riuscissimo a convincere
i nostri concittadini favara ad
investire di cui investire anche solo il
10 per cento del loro risparmio in
società per azioni buone avremmo domani
da spendere 50 milioni di euro per asili
i luoghi per bambini spazi per i
teenager housing sociale parcheggi
cooperative edilizie cooperative per la
gestione di servizi turistici per
formare e inserire i giovani nel mondo
del lavoro ma anche tutti quelli che
sono rimasti indietro papi ma come mai
non ci aveva mai pensato che sono forse
perché in questo modo è più facile per
tutti venderci azioni in petrolio in
carbone azioni bancarie e assicurative è
piuttosto che investire i nostri soldi
nelle nostre città la verità è che voi
adulti tante volte non pensate vi
complicate la vita e perdete di vista le
cose importanti non ben note a ciò che
conta veramente
forse abbiamo preferito fidarci di
banche assicurazioni e piuttosto
efficace il nostro compagno di banco di
scuola nel nostro vicino di casa
ok ma questa è un'utopia sì ma non più
grande di quella in cui dieci anni fa ma
metà vi pensarono e credettero di
trasformare il centro storico di favara
in una grande attrazione turistica e
culturale
e poi per caso vi viene in mente un
alternativa grazie
[Applauso]